[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اعقاب عمليتين
بالاغوار وتل ابيب قوات الاحتلال تعزز
اجراءاتها الامنيه بعد تعليمات بتعبئه كل
وحدات الاحتياط في قوات حرس الحدود وسط
حمله اعتقالات متفرقه في الضفه الاتحاد
الاوروبي يدعو لانهاء فوري للعنف ولندن
تدعو لتسويه تفضي الى حل الدولتين
[موسيقى]
تعلن ارسال غواصه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
ومزوده بصواريخ استراتيجيه الى الشرق
الاوسط ومسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان
الخطوه تاتي لدعم الامن والاستقرار اثرى
معلومات استخباريه تفيد بان ايران تعتزم
تنفيذ هجمات بالمنطقه قريبا الصين تبدا
مناورات عسكريه تحاكي تطويقا كاملا
لتايوان وتحذر مما تصفه بمساعي الانفصاليه
بالتواطئ مع قوى وفي لقاء مع مشرعين
امريكيين رئيسه تايوان تعبر عن تطلع
بلادها لتعزيز التعاون الامني مع واشنطن
في مواجهه ما وصفته بالتوسع الاستبدادي
الصيني باحثان برازيليان يعيدان رسم وجه
رجل من اصل افريقي عاش في مصر قبل 35 الف
عام باستخدام تقنيات المسح التصويريه حيث
اعتمدوا على بقايا هيكله العظمي لاعاده
انشاء صوره رقميه له مؤكدين ان هذه
التقنيه ستساعد علماء الاثار على تحديد
كيفيه التطور البشري الى اللقاء